[Musique]
les débats d'idées ont toujours été au
coeur de la vie démocratique
ici l'avènement des réseaux sociaux à
faciliter les échanges sur des questions
fondamentales
ces nouvelles plateformes ont aussi
favorisé l'émergence de débats portant
sur des questions autant banal que
polarise les dérapages des insultes
voire de la haine
tout ça pour des questions sans grande
importance et sans que cela soit
dramatique
on a d'ailleurs nous même expérimenté
des situations du genre au sein de notre
équipe
en ce qui vous concerne lanchettes voir
ce qui se passe ça commence au bureau
c'est l'étonnement débat savoir si un
hold up stores sandwich c'est un débat
qui se pressent chaque fois qu on pose
la question à quelqu'un les gens ont la
voix pignon forte il reste campé sur
leurs positions
c'est super pour la webcam grand
opération on va parler autour d'eux un
tueur dog ou deux ça fait aucun doute
que ça répond à la définition de ce
qu'un sandwich c'est à dire du pain avec
une garniture absolument pas ces points
109 101 ducks et les mots sont
importants
on appelle ça un top c'est quelque chose
de différent d'un sandwich vous avez à
en parler avec un certain calme mais ça
pas toujours été le cas et et vous
l'avez vu aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
là ça dégénère assez rapidement mais
justement c'est un débat qui fait rage
depuis assez longtemps sur internet les
gens sont très divisés et puis on a
lancé son aux réseaux sociaux et on a vu
en quelques heures
presque 200 commentaires les gens se
déchirer sur la question
et puis jusqu'à maintenant je dirais
qu'on a pas encore atteint de consensus
et les gens continuent sans même écouter
l'autre partie oui tout à fait et c'est
drôle parce qu'en regardant les quelques
200 commentaires qu'ont eu sur facebook
nous sommes dans cette question là je me
reconnaissais ça ressemble au débat
polarisant politique qu'on voit sur les
réseaux sociaux mais ce sens c'est
tellement banal débat comme celui là
mais c'est les mêmes caractéristiques
avec les débats politiques comment ça se
fait qu'on scolarise avec des enjeux
aussi comme cela
mais justement j'ai voulu comprendre
pourquoi ça vient autant le chercher
puis en fait en parlant avec un expert
en psychologie ce qui m'expliquait sait
qu'on a un instinct il est au tribalisme
on a besoin pour notre survie la êtres
humains de sentir qu'on fait partie d'un
groupe
les faits n'ont plus d'importance dans
le débat parce que les gens finissent
par s'identifier à leur camp et quand il
ya des leaders ensuite qu'il vienne
jouer sur cette polarisation le ça peut
encore plus exacerbé le débat
si les gens arrivent à trouver autre
chose qui les rassemble ils peuvent
arriver ensuite à être plus réceptifs à
écouter d'armes allons trouver quelque
chose qui vous ressemble
parce que si je pense qu'on peut
s'entendre que 2 go mais tout à fait
d'accord avec toi tu vois là ok